gaétan barrette bonsoir bonsoir vous
dites que vous êtes inspiré du modèle
kaiser pour votre réforme kaiser qu'un
fournisseur de soins américains privés à
but non lucratif qu'est ce que vous
voulez emprunter de ce système là
écoutez c'est un système très organisé
très uniformiser et qui a une structure
organisationnelle qui garantit l'accès
aux services comme vous l'avez vu dans
la voix partage d'une façon constante
elle en tout moment en tout lieu pour le
patient c'est vraiment vraiment vraiment
un système de santé parce qu'on peut
dire que c'est un système de santé
compte tenu de la grandeur qui est
absolument centrée sur le patient qui
centrée sur le patient mais quand même
il ya des choses qui sont très
particulières et qui je crois sur puce
peuvent s'appliquer au québec il s'est
basé sur trois éléments
tout est informatisé les médecins sont
salariés et ils sont très bien entouré
ya beaucoup de professionnels c'est
multidisciplinaire très intégrée alors
commençons par le système informatique
monsieur barrette ça fait dix ans qu'on
attend ça au québec
les systèmes sont toujours pas
compatible est ce que c'est pour bientôt
ça oui alors au québec d'ici la fin de
l'année toutes les données cliniques qui
appartient aux patients c'est à dire les
laboratoires la radiologie ces choses là
comme ça a été dit hier dans le
reportage vont être disponibles partout
au québec et en totalité actuellement la
problématique c'est que c'est pas en
totalité
pour ce qui est du salariat des médecins
parce que ça c'est vraiment un point
essentiel tous les médecins là bas sont
des salariés
alors est-ce que vous allez apporter ça
aussi non parce que et là dessus je vous
invite à poser la question fait des
raisons médicales
le scénario c'est une dynamique qui est
complètement différente
et vous savez le scénario il ya un
élément qui manquait dans le reportage
et rck 15 heures c'est un scénario il ya
un fonds de pension ça c'est une chose
qui serait réclamée par les dessins du
québec sont allés là mais dans le
scénario chez 15 heures il ya une
obligation
il ya des tâches qui sont imposés à
savoir qu'il y as description tanches et
dans le scénario de 15 heures il ya un
minimum de patients avoir par jour
qui était inférieur à ce que nous les
supérieurs à ce que nous on demande
ses 2500 francs par année et c'est un
minimum de 23 patients vus par jour et
je dis bien minimum sion ya d'epinay il
ya des puits des pénalités financières
si on a on ne rencontre pas ces
objectifs là alors j'imagine que vous
pouvez vous imaginer ce que serait la
réaction des médecins si demain matin je
mettais le salariat à la hauteur de
cazouls qui est nettement inférieur à ce
que les médecins du québec
mais est-ce qu'on a n'est pas rendu là
parce que tous beaucoup l'intervenant
disent que c'est une un des principaux
problèmes là la rémunération des
médecins à l'acte parce que dans le
reportage on le voyait quand même les
salariés ne sont pas payés à l'acte donc
ils ont pas besoin nécessairement de
voir le patient dans l'eure dans leur
bureau ils peuvent faire des choses par
mai mais au québec
oui mais au québec lucie madame galipeau
moi même lorsque j'étais de l'autre côté
de la table
j'ai négocié des tarifs de
téléconsultation par exemple tout à fait
faire ça au québec
si les médecins ne veulent mais ce qu'on
retient du reportage d'hier en pack jeu
seul mais c'était bien rapporté c'est
exact les chiffres que vous le confirmer
monsieur bilodeau lorsqu'il a fait son
reportage il nous a dit que c'était 10
millions de clients pour traiter et bien
servi par dix sept mille médecins
on est huit millions québec avec près de
20 mille médecins pour des services je
peux vous l'assurer comparables et quand
vous regardez les
les horaires de 15h ça a été bien
démontré dans le reportage de 8 heures à
18 heures saint geours semaine 46
semaines par année
je peux vous dire que ici son avis ce
rythme là un rythme et 15 est rien si
vous me le permettez il n'y aurait pas
assez de gens au québec pour fournir les
médecins c'est ça qui est la clé les
médecins travaillent pas assez
ce que je dis c'est que la capacité que
les médecins du québec peuvent offrir à
la population n'est pas maximale elle
n'est pas exploitée si les médecins au
québec offrait la capacité maximale
comme sécher détachées qu'ailleurs au
québec à la population du québec
il y aurait aucune attente mais quand
même ces quotas là que vous voulez
imposer aux médecins inquiète beaucoup
inquiété les passions et beaucoup de
médecins
je pense que les patients qui nous
écoutent s'attendent à ce que quelque
chose se passe pour qu'ils aient accès
notre paradigme il est clair au fil des
années il ya plus de médecins plus
d'argent moins de services l'eau vous
avez un modèle bien organisée qui arrive
à traiter et prendre en charge une
population de 10 millions de personnes
avec 17 bis le médecin on en a près de
20000 pour les 8 millions elle semble
qu'à un moment donné on doit se rendre à
l'évidence c'est quelque chose qui
marche fort qu'il va écrire
ouais mais dans notre reportage de lundi
sur une clinique du centre ville ya des
médecins qui ont vu un budget réduit de
40% avant l'élection d'ailleurs parce
que là on a enlevé on a éliminé la
pondération donc la pondération c'est
que par exemple pour un patient
séropositif qui comptait pour 4 patients
maintenant ils comptent pour un patient
une femme enceinte compter pour cette
passion maintenant bon ça ça a disparu
et là il s'inquiète avec les quotas
parce qu'ils ne veulent pas faire une
médecine mcdo on dit oui j'ai bien j'ai
bien retenu moi aussi l'expression mais
on
elle est la conséquence évidemment des
coupures du parti québécois là je veux
pas faire de politique
hier mais la 8 500 vient aussi oui je
comprends mais sauf que il y aura des
équivalences qui seront présentés dans
les prochaines semaines aux fédérations
médicales et je peux dire que les
équivalences qui ont été coupées par le
parti québécois moi ça me ça me scie et
lebron madame galipeau d'entendre que on
comptait un patient séropositif ou
toxicomanes pour un seul patient
moi je peux vous garantir que d'amateurs
d'équivalent ça soit pas utilisé les
médecins disent que dans le contexte
dans le contexte actuel avec un problème
de confiance qui existe il voulait que
ce soit par écrit il voulait savoir
exactement qu'est ce que vous aviez
l'intention de faire ce sera de
présenter par éléments qu'elle bouge peu
rassuré ses médecins locle et j'ai bien
écouté et je suis convaincu qu'avec le
système d'équivalence que l'on va
déposer vous allez pouvoir préfère le
même reportage et vous avez constaté que
ces gens là ne seront pas pénalisés
nouvelle clientèle particulière les plus
variables
oui c'est absolument impensable de
prendre un toxicomane personnes
dépressives de façon sévère et de le
compter pour un c'est impossible de le
compter pour ainsi cette impression qui
est en perte d'autonomie sévère en fin
de vie à la maison ça c'est mon
prédécesseur qui a décidé ça c'est pas
lui il disait que le principe légendaire
dit aujourd'hui que le principal
problème c'est la rémunération des
médecins à l'acte qu'il fallait pas
assez au salariat et que ça prenait
beaucoup de courage politique pour faire
ça il est un mini de la santé qui
médecins et les gens qui disent ça
qu'ils sont dus qui viennent du milieu
médical ou du milieu qui qui qui est
proche de la santé démontre leur
profonde incompréhension de ce qui fait
fonctionner un médecin ça rien à voir
maintenant galipeau le sérieux là je le
mets de même atteint là et ça veut dire
description de temps jeu ça veut dire
vacances ça veut dire pension ses visées
baisse de revenus pour les médecins
imaginez c'est de même atteindre parce
que là on va pas mettre plus d'argent
dans ce système là imaginez si demain
matin je dois mettre les médecins à
salles
1 et qu'en plus je doive leur donner un
régime de pension parce que le scénario
veut aussi dire bénéfices marginaux
pensez vous vraiment que les médecins du
québec vont vont accepter ça alors là
vous dites ce sera pas le salariat
l'informatique ça s'en vient
mais quelle est votre vision alors
qu'est-ce que comment voulez emprunter
des choses à kaiser vous voulez
l'appliquer comment alors alors
actuellement sur selon le projet de loi
veil devrait faire surtout lorsque les
médecins constateront les équivalences
on demande aux médecins de modifier à la
base leur façon de pratiquer la médecine
pour l'après-ski comme chez 15 heures et
ça s'appelle l'axé adapté l'axé adapté
madame galipeau c'est simple ça demande
d'être la première main on demande aux
médecins d'être présent cinq jours
semaine pendant 45 de travailler plus
les salaires ben oui m'écouter il a
demandé cinq jours semaine pendant
quarante semaines si c'est l'enfer ben
je suis beaucoup de monde qu'ils
écoutent actuellement qui sont tous
d'accord alors on demande aux gens
d'avoir une pratique qui n'est plus
organisé autour du rendez vous annuel
périodiques par exemple mais une
pratique où on inscrit des gens et où on
ceux pour lesquels on se rend disponible
c'est ça que 15 à 15 heures on est les
médecins sont disponibles le scénario
comme c'était bien d'hier ne cède pas à
faire venir les personnes et c'est pas
ça qu'on a entendu aux médecins d'être
disponible mais dans la période qui
s'est acquis et appropriée l'axé adapté
tous les médecins et malheureusement ils
sont très peu nombreux qui ont hâte de
qui ont adopté ce profil de pratique là
aujourd'hui non plus d'attendre
et il inscrit des co auteurs comme vous
dites plus grand que ce que l'on demande
à l'opposé de ceux qui ont une pratique
plus traditionnelles qui construisent
leur grille de rendez vous sur des
rendez-vous de périodiques annuel par
exemple qui font en sorte que des gens
qui ont pas nécessairement besoin
d'aller voir les médecins vont les voir
à la place de dole qui en auraient
besoin
alors on verra et on suivra les
développements merci beaucoup de
monsieur marc est merci merci quand même